Enemies to the East
enemies to be enemies to the West
enemies to the south
enemies to the north whatever stands in our way
we will defeat it
we're the last lannisters
the last ones who count
I was born to rule the Seven Kingdoms
and I will
The King In the North!
Your father and brothers are gone, yet here you stand
last best hope against the coming storm
if we don't put aside our enmities and
band together we will die
and then it doesn't matter whose skeleton sits on the iron throne
the Great War is here
happy Game of Thrones day they finally
dropped the season 7 trailer there's a
new round of the game of Thrones
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video there are so many big beats here
so I'll talk about all the big stuff
then I'll go through shot-by-shot so
let's do this, we jumped from Cersei she
gets dialogue then to Daenerys talking
about how she was born to rule Cersei is
making War then Jon Snow talking about
the wars to come even Davos is talking
about not coming together we will fall
the coming darkness is too great as they
show you a bunch of wildlings including
Jon Snow running through the frozen
north so we're going to be going all
over Westeros in ways that we've never
seen that's why they show you the maps
at the beginning of the trailer we saw
what Cersei walking into that table
room you get a shot of grey worm of the
unsullied all the different forces you
see the map table at Dragonstone when
she's talking about enemies to the west
you see these ships that's talking about
the Greyjoy's and their fleet there's a
hand that sticks out here it's got
greyscale guess who that is that's sir
Jorah he's back I mean we knew he was
coming back but it's so awesome that
they show that first like they don't
show you his face they show you the hand
that's gotten even worse and yes I do
think that he's going to be a big
presence in season 7 but it looks like
he has not found someone to cure that
yet and then you know we see Cersei
rally herself we will crush them all as
you see all these Lannister soldiers
walk by we've seen Lannister armies but
not looking this awesome so far, you see
Jaime standing next to her in the iron
throne room Tyrion standing out on the
cliffs as he watches the Dragons rise up
the dragons have come to Dragonstone so they raised balerion the black dread a
bunch of other dragons they're back in
the time of Aegon the conquerer so it is
a natural roost for dragons there are caverns beneath dragonstone so hopefully we'll
get to see them you see Daenerys touch
the beachfront she's named Daenerys
Stormborn because she was born there but she hasn't been back there since she was
a little baby they fled just as she was
being born you get a better shot of
Casterly Rock the unsullied just pouring
in so this is obviously on the other
side of Westeros so we're jumping around
in time as we jump through the trailer
then you jump to the shot of Jon Snow at
Winterfell
but little
finger gets the voiceover whispering in
Sansa's ear you're the last best hope
your father and brothers are dead so it
sounds like you get a couple shots of
him in the hallways it sounds like he is
definitely going to try and get Sansa to
move against Jon Snow Jon Snow looks
like he's down here in the crypts
getting ready to wreck him next to the
statue of his mother that he might not
know is his mother yet so either littlefinger is
going to play with that idea or
Jon Snow is just going to get tired of
his bullshit but I think that if
someone's going to get rid of littlefinger
they should give that to Sansa
just because it's so much more
meaningful to her character but Jon Snow
just ain't going to be taking anybody's
crap you start getting more shots of the
frozen north this is the gate at castle black
up at the other side of the wall
you see a shot of Theon that looks like
he's on one of these boats in his big
explosion here you see all these big
battles going on this battle at the sea
looks like it gets a little help from
the Dragons just because the ship is
burning so fast more of Arya making her
way even further north a lot of snow on
the ground so it doesn't look like it's
going to be too long before she arrives
at Winterfell this shot of the Dothraki
bloodrider riding into battle looks like
it might also be from this scene here
with them on this big field of
engagement which rogue on rising behind
them so all the while jumping back and
forth between people looking at their
maps making their plans
Daenerys in front of the math table her
ancestor Aegon the conquerer is the one
that had that table built right before
the conquest not really sure who re is
trying to find here but she might
actually finally be back in Winterfell
looking underneath the bed just trying
to find things that she may have hidden
when she was a little girl but one of my
favorite shots here is Jon Snow in the
furs running through the frozen north
they're supposed to be a really big
action set piece set around the White
Walkers late in the season so this is
probably what that's from
you get a little Missandei and grey
worm action and then just riding into
battle the Great War is here so
obviously he's talking about the war
with the White Walkers
but you see new costumes for almost
everybody to near us at Dragonstone you
see the mountain in a crazy-looking
kingsguard version of Cersei's armor that
she's been wearing since the end of last
season you get a better look at the
dragons and it almost looks like
Melisandre is going to be with Daenerys
as she
watching them walk up that winding
staircase now we know where she is it
looks like it's not going to be too long
before she gets a reunion with Jon Snow
answer Davos if he comes to Dragonstone
with him
so that reminds you of that Davos line
if we don't come together put our
differences aside we're all going to be
dead but doesn't that make you wonder
what Cersei's final fate is going to be
especially if Daenerys is going to sack
Casterly Rock this place that you
thought was untouchable for most of
Tywin's adult life is Lord of Casterly
Rock the Lannisters were untouchable
then you started seeing a couple of dead
children dropping like flies
Jaime got captured got his hand cut off
so they are being backed into a corner
but the really cool thing about Jaime
now is that he's not a member of the
Kingsguard anymore so he is Lord of
Casterly Rock and he's wielding widow's
wail one of the two Valyrian swords that
they reforge from the melted down ice
the great sword of Ned Stark so there
are a couple big reasons why they might
have done that George rr Martin said that
in the books what happened is his after
Joffrey died they sent that to Casterly
Rock so we might get to see Jaime there
maybe that's where he grabs that sword
or maybe Cersei just orders him to start
using it but the really cool thing here
is that now that the wars are heating up
we might get a moment where Brienne is
forced to fight Jamie with Oathkeeper so
you wind up with a situation with the
sword of Ned Stark fighting itself or
even if they fight together
you basically have ice between the two
of them so if they're either fighting
together they're fighting against each
other it provides for this really
amazing metaphor no matter what but I'm
really hoping that if Cersei goes down
and Jamie's the one to do it
he does it with widow's wail how poetic
would that be you get the valonqar
prophecy don't know if the show's going
to do that but we can all keep our
fingers crossed but ending her with the
sword that was forged for her son which
is jumping around in time you can seize
a lot of these conflicts in Westeros
especially Daenerys going after Casterly
Rock looks like it happens relatively
early in the season especially the
Greyjoy fights the stuff that's
happening way up in the frozen north
doesn't look like it happens till much
later in the season because of the way
they cut the trailer they talk about
enemies all around us we'll crush them
all so you have all these engagements
Daenerys is mostly focused on taking the
iron throne everybody is concerned with
the wars that are happening in the south
they're not really concerned with the
stuff that's happening in the north with
the exception of John Snow in Davos now
that we see that Melisandre is with
Daenerys she might try to convince her
of the threat of the White Walkers and
help bridge the gap between her and Jon
Snow but we also know about maester
Marwan who does not appear in the
trailer he helps Samwell at the Citadel
so there are a number of characters that
are very concerned with the Great War in
addition to Jon Snow they can help
convey a lot of information to the other
characters they don't really know about
that yet
especially Cersei she has no idea what's
going on in the frozen north but let me
know in the comments what do you guys
think about all this and what do you
think it's going to take to get Cersei
to help out with what's going on in the
north or do you think she's never going
to help do you think that they're going
to crush her and we'll wind up with a
version of Daenerys as vision coming
true with King's Landing in the iron
throne room just burn to a husk with all
this snow falling down winter has come
so obviously we're going to be talking
about a whole bunch of this in the next
couple of bonus videos but let me know
what you want my next game of Thrones
video to be about that'll probably post
in the next couple of days there's so
much to unpack from this and it's just
the beginning you're going to start
seeing a lot more of HBO promoting Game of Thrones now that we're heading into
the summer less than two months to go
we're almost there so there will be a
lot of white Walker things happening in
the north and they even use the night
King to promote that motion post or a
couple days ago so they really want you
to be thinking about White Walkers even
though none of them appear anywhere in
this footage so I'll name the giveaway
winner when I post that longer video
while you wait for that you can click
here for more promo breakdowns and you
can click here to learn all about what's
going on up in the north thank you so
much for watching let's I thought I'll
see you guys in a little while